we're back in the 1990s for the first
awesome Captain Marvel trailer and boy
does it look fantastic
yippie ki movie lovers it's Jan here and
in this video I'm breaking down the
trailer for loads of marvelous Easter
eggs and crucial details you might have
missed and to celebrate the Captain
Marvel trailer I'm kicking off a new
superhero giveaway so make sure you're
subscribed to my channel and leave me a
comment below on the trailer for a
chance to win the first detail you might
have missed comes in this brief shot in
a lab deep inside a shield building if
you zoom in really close you'll see Nick
Fury with a gun presumably ready in case
the Skrull on the operating table wakes
up and noticed how Fury is holding what
looks like some kind of cold pack on his
left eye now obviously elsewhere in the
trailer we see a younger fury before the
injury that led him to wear the eye
patch in the other MCU movies so I think
what we may be seeing in this scene is
the aftermath of a fight with a squirrel
which caused Fury's left eye injury and
led him to have to wear an eyepatch also
facing away from us is someone else who
looks like it could be Ben Mendelsohn
you might know him as cranek from rogue
one but in Captain Marvel he's playing
the alien squirrel Talos who arrives on
earth and shape-shifts into human form
to hide among us in plain sight
Talos is the leader of the Skrulls
who've been at war with the alien career
ace and he arrives on earth to pose as a
SHIELD agent and secretly lay the
groundwork for a Skrull invasion and
this scene gives us a glimpse of how
perfectly he seems to be blending in and
as that shot of Talas and Nick Fury
appears the trailer drops the following
voiceover line from samuel l.jackson
space invasion now that's another subtle
indication that Captain Marvel is
drawing from The Secret Invasion comic
book crossover storyline in that story
it's revealed that the shape-shifting
Skrulls have actually taken the place of
many of Marvel superheroes so it'll be
interesting to see if the Captain Marvel
movie gives any hints as to whether any
of our favorite MCU characters are
actually secret squirrel imposters and
that shocking shot of Captain Marvel
thumping what appears to be a poor old
lady on the train might have confused
you if you weren't familiar with the
scrolls but I suspect Carole's seen
whoever she was chasing on top of the
Train shape-shift into a human form or
it
could be that something in the way the
old lady smiles at Carol triggers a
memory or reaction from her Cree
background making her think this woman's
a scroll so you're not from around here
it's hard to explain the trailer also
teases some cool new details about
captain Marvel's origins which as carol
danvers says are definitely complicated
marbles confirm this won't be your
typical superhero origin story as the
movie will begin with Carol Danvers
already having her powers and she'll be
part of a Kree elite unit called Star
Force the trailer teases a few shots of
her fellow [ __ ] mates on the right of
Carol Danvers and the star force shot is
Minerva played by Jemma Chan Minerva is
an elite sniper and was the star of the
team before Carol joined so you can
expect some rivalry between them in the
movie does Cora thir who love scene in
guardians the galaxy is the cream
mercenary who'd been sent by Thanos to
retrieve the orb which contained the
power stone because we're going back in
time this will be a younger carafe
though he's still played by the same
actor I suspect that the Captain Marvel
movie will show us why he and Ronan
ended up a lying themselves with Thanos
by the time of the guardians of the
galaxy movie by the way Ronan appears
very briefly in the trailer with his
back to us in this shot here in charge
of the team is Jude Law whose character
I think could be responsible for wiping
Carroll's memories I keep having these
memories messy flashes I think I had a
life here
but I can't tell if it's real the
assumption so far was laws characters
that he's playing mahvel however
nobody's been able to confirm who his
character actually is meaning it could
be part of a twist let me know what you
think okay so this is a scene of an
experiment or procedure that I suspect
Jude Law's character may be performing
on Carol interviews with brie Larson and
Kevin Feige have confirmed Captain
Marvel is part human and part Cree in
the movie as in the comics and let's
just say this scene feels like she's
being turned into a Kree Winter Soldier
this could be a twist on how she
receives her powers in the comics where
she was caught in a special piece of
curry technology that altered her DNA
making her a human Creek High Bridge
with superhuman powers based on the
trailer there is another possibility for
how carol gets her powers and that's
when she approaches some wreckage and
seems to be enveloped in a wave of blue
light this might also match with another
shot in the trailer where she falls back
and then you see blue light around her
hand an earlier version of the beeper
that we saw in the Avengers infinity war
post-credits scene makes an appearance
in the trailer although it's different
the buttons which a visible do seem to
match the device used in infinity war
the later version appears to be an
enhanced or augmented model with
additional attachments to the top and
bottom the infinity war model is also
aged significantly and the extra pieces
may be necessary to be able to
communicate with Captain Marvel wherever
she's located at the time of Thanos
acquiring the Infinity Gauntlet there's
also some really interesting
foreshadowing for Avengers 4 in this bit
of voice over from Nick Fury we can't do
this alone
we need youth I think we'll hear that
line towards the end of this film
perhaps as Captain Marvel's having to
leave Earth for some reason Nick Fury
will probably be letting Carol know that
he may need to use the beeper to contact
her again in the case of an emergency
which is of course exactly what happens
at the end of infinity war there's also
an intriguing line at the end of the
trailer I'm not what you think I am
notice is ahead just at the bottom of
the frame I think that could be Monica
Rambeau the daughter of Maria Rambo
who's Carol's Air Force colleague and
friend who we see earlier in the trailer
Maria Rambo Monica's mother goes by the
call-sign photon and in the comics her
daughter Monica is actually the first
female Captain Marvel this is an
interesting Easter Egg II twist of sorts
and probably a wink by Marvel to comic
book fans but what I think is happening
in this scene is that either Carole is
revealing her superhero alter ego to her
fellow pilot Maria or perhaps Maria has
died and Carole's telling her friend's
daughter that she's not the right person
to look after her and if that is the
young Monica in the bottom of the shot
then it might be a tease for a future
super-powered Monica Rambeau in the MCU
another comic book nod comes with
several shots of Carol Danvers with a
helmet and if you look here you can see
the helmets being used to create a
classic mohawk haircut from the comics
and let's just appreciate this amazing
final shot of Captain Marvel fully
powering up glowing bright and her eyes
turning into pure light captain Marvel's
powers include the ability to absorb
huge amounts of cosmic energy and when
she takes on enough she goes binary and
there's a cool Easter egg on the Captain
Marvel poster as well if you look very
carefully you'll spot the tail end of a
cat here
that's a nod to the comics where Carol
has a pet cat called chewy named after
Chewbacca from Star Wars the thing is
that chewy isn't actually a cat it's a
member of an alien species called the
Fleur Kim and there was another illusion
to the feline like alien on some Captain
Marvel cupcakes given out at an event
held at Marvel Studios notice that
cupcake with what looks like a cat's ID
tag decoration on it well that's happy
internet wondering where the kite book
Chiri will be renamed in the MCU as
goose now would seem of
weird given that Disney owns Star Wars
but then again it would certainly fit
well with the Top Gun illusions in the
trailer also on the poster of the words
higher further faster which is a tagline
from Captain Marvel's comics
specifically a run by writer Kelly sue
Taconic whose work has been a particular
influence on this film so did the
trailer get you hyped for the Captain
Marvel movie and what other details or
Easter eggs did you spot let me know
your thoughts and theories and make sure
you leave a comment and subscribe for a
chance to win a cool Funko pop tapleft
to check out another Captain Marvel
video or tap write for another video
you're sure to like and if you enjoyed
this a thumbs up and a share are always
really appreciated thanks for watching
and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers